and then when he said that he would
potentially put him on hormone blockers
I just kept retweeting like are you guys
seeing this are you seeing the madness
and the silence I got from all my shiny
blue checkmark friends you'll lose your
soul doing that stuff welcome to the
show louder with Crowder I have a
confession to make
by now you may have realized that I am
actually a steven crowder impersonator
it's not really Crowder it's me Owen I'm
I have the honor and the privilege to
guest host today and apparently I'm also
modeling Men's Wearhouse discount suits
but it's great to be here and we have a
very very very special third chair yay
dr. Owen I'm just happy to be here
Ankush I'm Kate today we're gonna talk
about the top 5 ways leftist sexualized
kids yeah question of the day why do you
think the left is pushing sex on kids
it's such young ages have you spent any
time considering their motives and the
implications of their actions please
comment we want to know because we don't
really know and if we want to stop these
people this thing um in many areas of
our culture and society the left cannot
wait to sexualize children for being so
offended by everything they're hungry to
do one of the worst possible things you
can do seems every day there's another
story about the left
pushing sex on our kids we're gonna
limit this to just 5 there's an insane
amount of examples but we got to keep it
to five otherwise I will become enraged
and blow my brains out yeah well there's
a gun on your desk and so let's not do
that right no yeah that's 5-5-5 not
loaded yeah we tried six earlier and a
run through in it got carry so yeah if
there was a seven plus one out
definitely this is disturbing I'm just
gonna be straight up and this is real
this is really happening so I'm glad
that we get to just just know this is
real number five is a weird sex ed we
know there are some weird sex ed
programs in public schools and Canada
pushing sex ad that teaches
homosexuality in grade 3 what three
grade three masturbation in grade six oh
my gosh that's in in public school oral
and anal sex in grade seven
gotta be kidding me now this is real as
well as teaching there are six genders
rather than two biological sexes these
teachers are the authority figures that
your children are with all day every day
they look to these people for guidance
yeah and the state mandates that we pay
them to confuse and traumatize our
children's insane but this may be the
most bizarre taxpayer-funded sex
education show ever the peculiar and
confusing act that just play that just
play the clip just watch it for yourself
[Applause]
this be blurred oh my gosh ah those are
kids there's kids around there my gosh
like Jim Henson meets Rosemary's Baby
and you see this this oh my gosh
this puppet woman give birth and be
beaten to death by a brick and but
everything I was made a lot more sense
when it was revealed that the puppet did
have information that would lead to the
arrest of one Hillary Rodham Clinton and
something else made happen a Planned
Parenthood puppet then just appeared
quickly and beat the baby with a brick
yeah well that's what they disagreement
there they put on this nightmare
inspiring exhibit the name of this is
snuff puppets a snuff film is when you
kill someone on camera a snuff puppet is
when you kill a child's innocence
apparently they call it snuff puppets oh
my gosh these guys suck the lesson also
included the now dead mother spraying
the children with simulated breast milk
I didn't realize when they say Australia
is down under they mean it's literally
in hell all right number for accepting
pedophile celebrities when it yeah when
it comes to celebrities leftists have a
long history of ignoring pedophilia here
is a room full of lefties cheering
convicted child rapist Roman Polanski
followed by Whoopi Goldberg defending
him goes to Roman Polanski
charged I know it wasn't rain three yeah
there is a statutory child molest maybe
I was something else but I don't believe
it was raped with ray Polanski rape
rabies I passed out and drugged 13-year
old girl at a party at Jack Nicholson's
house that that uh that shaded that
whole guy who was whistling at this by
the way in the video but who's to judge
right I mean that must fall into the
gray area of consent but God forbid
judge Kavanagh admit to consuming a beer
and having a yearbook right now that's
rape rape I mean that woman did lie
about something from 40 years ago but
that little 13 year old girl that was
sodomized and by the way I take no joy
in talking about this man people have to
literally see this you know they can't
look away and they can't agree to this
right and there are plenty of other
celebrities who have allegedly groomed
and molested children we call these
people and open secrets Michael Jackson
Asia Argento Kevin Spacey Woody Allen
haff the set of Nickelodeon shows
several of which are rehired after
they're convicted of child rape kind of
like Bryan Peck serious yeah oh yeah
yeah convicted of child rape and then
rehired by Nickelodeon no way oh yeah
and of course the director of x-men is a
widely acknowledged sexual predator of
children who for a living is an
authority position around children yeah
that being said hit the notification
bell I have to remind you to subscribe
and hit the notification bell thank you
for that just subscribing means nothing
these days apparently we have to ring a
bell for some reason hit like comment
share this to your friends
we aren't super liked by the algorithm
monster so that little extra help
spreading the word the comedy hasn't
been completely eaten by Amy Schumer not
that she hasn't tried she's tried tried
tried hard you gave me punchlines
that's unfunny let's keep going on this
horrifying adventure number three
normalizing pedophilia as an orientation
this is one of my up alright let me just
just keep hammering here
another thing leftists have pushed is
the idea that pedophilia is just another
sexual orientation like being gay or
straight stop discrimination it's time
to be more tolerant of demons who feed
on kids yeah let's be more inclusive of
satanic predators like a while back a
bunch of leftist sites like salon and
vice did profiles on this non-offending
pedophile named Todd Nickerson I am a
pedophile I'm not a monster
I have the tractions that I don't act on
it that's like a pedophile he's the
definition of a monster daughter did
that one a friend's daughter did that
one in the new friend's daughter did
that one seems like he likes friends
daughters yeah cuz they know I'm not I
am no danger to them probably safer with
me than they are with like you know a
lot of non pedophile
they're safer with a rabid wolf yeah the
idea being it's okay for him to want to
bang kids as long as he doesn't actually
bang kids of course he never would wink
wink
except nickerson posts he would have sex
with kids if we just lived in a more sex
positive society x+ what the hell does
that mean I'll tell you what it means
Todd Nickerson is the reason ar15 exists
predators always want to normalize
that's what they do ask yourself this
would lions or would zebras benefit from
the removal of categories and stigma the
Lions would keep pushing for inclusivity
and have retreated just like lions
predators are discriminated don't use
your sis prey privilege and then once
everyone's guard is down the Lions will
just feast I don't have to go anywhere
right there isn't it among them it's not
so true though it's like don't judge me
for being obviously a predator yeah
number two I can't but
all right transit I think we need like a
throw up break for people like if you
need to go throw up and come back yeah I
just need a curse and already ups in the
face exactly transitioning kids if it
weren't enough to sexualize kids the
left now encourages them to make
permanent irreversible changes to
bodies yeah this isn't some fringe
leftist idea here's NBC pushing this on
national television increasingly
families are going public with what it
means to be a transgender kid it means
you're being abused exactly five
year-olds are fears
he loves karate and dogs and shapes and
playing with his sisters why can't why
can't a regular girl like Rogers or the
brother right they can this is an
abscess I'm not always what were you
before I'm there's my sister how come it
changed because I want it to be a boy
okay in the beginning Minnie and Joe
LeMay were raising three girls still are
Mia was around two she started saying
I'm a boy all right I mean it's it's I
have a two and a half year old son like
watching that stuff makes my blood
literally boil yeah
all right so two-year-olds are old and
wise enough to make the decision to
change gender
no wonder pedophile leftists think they
can consent to sex there's what's all
about it's about consent yeah oh and
this hits extra home with me because I
was at CAA I had a book deal with a big
publisher I was on a sitcom and Comedy
Central specials on his stuff and I
called out a guy for doing this very
thing on Twitter and I know I've told
this story before but I don't want
people to forget that this is real a
five a five year old was told he was a
girl and this guy was giving he was
given all this virtue for he saw oh
we're victims and then when he said that
he would potentially put him on hormone
blockers I just kept retweeting like are
you guys seeing this are you seeing the
madness and the silence I got from all
my shiny blue checkmark friends and then
people saying apologize or we have to
let you go and I literally want to do
tree work for 20 bucks an hour with my
brother after just being on a TV show
because I'm like that will lose you'll
lose your soul doing that stuff agreeing
with it is just as bad what that just as
bad but it's like how can people stay
silent yes just mind blowing the cost of
agreeing to that is you literally lose
your own instincts you don't even trust
yourself that's what happens with a lot
of
self-hating behaviors because they
literally hate themselves because they
know what they've done and they know
what they've agreed to all right can you
remember what you thought when you were
this age to see this nothing about
myself
oh yeah exactly I thought I was a
dinosaur imagine if extent instead of
actual parents that I fortunately I did
and do have love you mom and dad now
that I know that this exists extra love
you mom and dad imagine if I had those
dead I sjw parents who used my childhood
divert you signal to their awful friends
and they surgically added dinosaur
scales that I could never remove in a
fake tail and then made me take hormone
blockers so I never had any adult human
characteristics oh my gosh human that's
real it's essentially what's going on
here a hundred percent the dinosaur
phase would pass and as I grew up I'd
enter a phase where instead I'd want to
be a dead person because 40% of these
kids killed themselves
and before you say that's because of
societal oppression that's a higher
suicide rate than prisoners and ouch
wits Oh kids want to make their parents
happy that that's why this drives me and
saying is these kids are like how do I
get love and acceptance from my parents
exactly and think about how easy it is
to victimize these children like my son
plays piano at two because I do it yeah
you know I want to believe it's just
god-given town because he's good at it
but it's also he just wants to because I
do he builds things with Legos because I
say good job it's like these kids happen
to have parents whose approval of them
is it rests on a chemistry experiment so
they can claim victim status at cocktail
parties and get more social status and
money on on the backs of their kids
futures it's just insane
all right and number one and then I'll
let you guys out of this horror show and
that this is real and then some of you
guys won't want to believe it this is
all real child drag queens
oh wow a lot of progressive outlets have
done profiles on on child drag queens
for example here is ten-year-old drag
queen Desmond and in case you thought
that was a one-off there's also an eight
year old drag queen named lacked Asia
my name is Desmond is amazing I see
myself and LGBTQ activists um a drag
head my motto is be yourself always no
matter what anyone says that is a boy
Desmond's has gotten a lot of
well-deserved attention recently because
a he's really young and be because he's
so fierce lactation is the devious diva
you can ever think of I've been lying
like my sister's too too since I was
like Three's and fours even like twos
that I've been dancing around in like
little pink dresses and stuff so yeah I
think I've had lactation inside of me
since I was born and that's why I love
that song belong this way we just want
our kids to express their people yeah
they want over trying to make judgments
here but I'm like what are the parents
doing yet well there you go you saw it
right there right well they don't want
people to be lactation intolerant
aggresses try to claim there's nothing
sexual about child drag queens that it's
just playing dress-up
but then they post a pic of lactation
wearing a onesie from an adult clothing
store and holding a balloon that says
eat a beep oh my gosh that right there
is the face of a society that's overly
tolerant to monsters that's the end
result of the millions and millions of
tiny little concessions that people make
daily so they aren't called intolerant
by people on Facebook or they get a
little extra money that is the result of
not defending our kids there's
definitely nothing sexual about that eat
it yes
LGBTQ AI is hungry for that P Caitlyn
Jenner playing dress up as an adult is
one thing but going after kids is
another evil needs to snuff out good and
there's nothing more good than kids this
is a way to hide abuse in plain sight
nothing to make these nothing makes
these people more excited than an entire
society so frozen by the threat of
getting a thumbs down on Facebook that
they accept the sexual exploitation of
their own children the left projects
what it is that they're trying to do and
in this case it's sexualizing mainstream
America to accept pedophilia in order to
have their way with children without any
op
you were if you liked this video you
first up should probably seek counseling
but you should subscribe or hit the
notification Bell or watch one of these
videos that's playing what the truth is
I don't know what any of that means
anymore if you try and subscribe its
notification Bell you won't be notified
and if you try to click one of these
videos it's just going to take you to
BuzzFeed boldly fat prods as they get
carried out of their houses relate to
break down the north wall and they get
carried out in a land well tarp I don't
know what's happening on YouTube I know
what's happening with mug Club ladders
credit.com slash month let me get to
watch The Daily Show one hour every
single day not just clips along with
like 15 other shows for 69 dollars
annually if your student and/or veteran
or military and you get to keep us here
on YouTube for free because we can we
can irritate them by your support it's
worth it right